senior writer Diego could be he can
check out the MQB podcast with Albert
brewery up on iTunes right now Albert
joins me here on the show Albert we were
talking about Gerry Jones's defense of
Ezekiel Elliott and look it's one thing
to defend your player but I took
exception with his comments that there
really wasn't as she said side to this
when it's pretty obvious there is a she
said side to this what did you make of
Joan's defense of his star player well
Jerry's been very much in the corner
really throughout you know this goes
back to last fall he appealed to people
the NFL offices and wanted to get the
process moving and you know I think a
big part of this Chris and they won't
ever fit this group one of the things
that's been frustrating to the Cowboys
the league has a way of doing this with
players but they may not fully trust
where they don't intentionally drag
their feet it's almost like you know
de-facto public probationary period
where something happens and the league
opens an investigation and the legal
leaves the investigation open and kind
of let things play out for a little
while and see if a guy can keep his nose
clean and Spurs eke you know you had the
incident last summer and then after the
season we had what happened on st.
Patrick's Day and we had what happened
last Sunday night so there's been you
know this pattern it doesn't really
relate to the domestic incident it goes
back to some of the issues he had with
partying at Ohio State where the league
whatsit and says well can we trust this
guy and if we're going to you know give
this guy a punishment that's kind of a
little bit more of a hey you better
watch your watch out now is he going to
make us look bad on the other end of it
and you know that's part of I think what
we saw with Josh Gordon too you know
it's part of what what this has been for
Zeke Kelly and I think it's frustrated
the Cowboys because they want to find a
way one way or the other to move past it
and unfortunately because he hooked up a
couple times since the incident in the
summer who leaves off this thing open
and you know I think Jerry's just trying
to drive a conclusion now how do you
think the NFL eventually
means on all this I think he has his
tort suspension that's my guess and part
of this and you may remember going back
to and this is the end the last decade
was when when when Roethlisberger got in
trouble and Vick got in trouble
you know one of the things that they
they try to emphasize the players was it
doesn't have to you know if you have an
altercation doesn't have to be you
throwing the punch its are you putting
yourself in situations where you're
going to make your team in league with
that and I think that's part of that
that whole campaign protect the shield
and everything else I think that's
what's going to happen here with Zeke
where it's you know you we may not have
been able to find guilt but you put
yourself in a position to make your team
and make the league with that and for
that we're going to teach you a lesson
and so my guess would be that there's
going to be a short suspension here and
you know I think that the hope is both
from the team standpoint early example
even though they may disagree on this
particular matter
that this will be the thing that will
kind of create the wake-up call that
both I think both groups think suite
needs second Albury or senior writer
Sports Illustrated the enemy could be
joining us here Dan Patrick show ah
Richard Sherman says all's well in
Seattle right now he and Russell Wilson
no problems there said I'm paraphrasing
but said they're not the best of friends
in the world but they're 100% great as
teammates you believing that
everything's behind in Seattle I think
it's a sign of it has been which is I
mean look you know if when you're
winning isn't seen as healthy tension
you know when you're when you're not
getting the Super Bowl and the window
seems to be closing you know attention
kind of go in the wrong direction
sometimes but I I felt for a long time
like the Seahawks is sort of thrived in
this this healthy tension and there's
that energy in that building that's the
way the Pete Carroll built that place
for that matter that's the way the Pete
Carroll be a built usc's program for all
those years and so you know I think a
big part of this is going to be you know
the defense getting back to where where
it has been the last few years and then
the offense being able to shoulder the
low
load and we've seen this in the past
with teams and you know you go way back
Pittsburgh Baltimore where teams that
are historic on defense or had a chance
to really create a lasting legacy on the
defensive side of the ball and have to
carry their office there is that healthy
tension sometimes and sometimes that can
Porter on that unhealthy tension in fact
you saw it even more recently with the
Jets when Rex Ryan was there it's just I
mean look you know it's a winning going
to be that is manageable if they're if
they're not and and they're not in the
final eight you know like they have in
the last five years then it becomes
something else you know a lot of this is
going to ride on whether or not they
succeed on the field you know I thought
it was a smart move by the Lions to
invite Calvin Johnson to come to
training camp to sort of you know was it
a PR move was it a real offer I'm not
exactly sure at this point but what do
you think the chances are that we ever
see Calvin Johnson on NFL field again I
don't think he's coming back
let me look the frustration with the
Lions organization was part of his
retirement but I don't think it was a
number one factor you know as I
understand it the number one thing was
really what it was taking that last year
to get him back on the field from a
physical standpoint how beat up he was
and then the process he'd have to go
through every offseason of getting
himself back in shape and ready to go
again
second we're on guys and you know I
thought the losing plays into that but I
mean that last year you know they they
were you know like that that last year
he was in Detroit you know I know was
was frustrating for him from a physical
standpoint and I just I don't look at
this as one of those things where you
know the guy is you know has one off
seasons and looks at and says now okay
you know I'm ready to go again
it should be hard for him physically to
get back in a position where he's ready
to play again and you know what we're
seeing now from the organization is a
new team president and general manager
saying to gente well things have changed
here we'd like you to come in and check
it out and see how much things have
changed here so you can have a
relationship with you going for but I
don't think he's ever going to play
second album prayer senior and the MQB
comm joining me here on the Dan Patrick
show I was reading a piece that a guy
that you work with and I know in Boston
Mike grd wrote are reported I guess on
Jimmy Garoppolo and I know what you know
what I'm referring to we wrote on
Facebook and it's I finished reading
that Albert it's like maybe Jimmy
Garoppolo is the next great quarterback
in the NFL I mean it's you know the the
effusive praise from the scouts he
talked to when the the former Patriots
player then we up against I mean this I
don't know what to make of it is that
are we now thinking that maybe Jimmy
Garoppolo is the the heir apparent to
Tom Brady er what are your thoughts well
cuz I think this is the most underrated
storyline v NFL offseason the caters
hung on to Jimmy Garoppolo the reason
why I mean you have to consider what
they gave up here and what they could
have got I mean right now they had him
was a year left on his rookie contract
so you're trading off to another team
and that team community hold him on the
roster at 1 million dollars for 2017 or
you just as leverage in the long term
negotiation this wasn't a great draft
year for quarterbacks this wasn't a
great Free Asia year for quarterbacks
and Jimmy Garoppolo is played recently
he played two games just nine months ago
so get all that going for you to pay to
the Patriots and that market was there
for next year Sam Bradford could be in
the market drew Brees could be on the
market Kirk Cousins could be in the
market the draft class promises to be a
lot better with guys like Rosen and
Arnold and Alan and oh by the way he's
going to be on the franchise tag if
you're trying to trade him next year so
the Patriots gave up yeah it just what
would have been significant value coming
back to keep them on the roster in 2017
to me that leaves the door wide open for
Jimmy Garoppolo to be the quarterback in
2018 and and my sense of it is this is
Bill saying it's great that Tom Brady
was that good at 39 and we're confident
that he can be that guy get again at 40
but it would be foolish of us to give up
on a to trade away a guy who we believe
in who's 25 years old
position and do that on the bet that Tom
Brady's going to be the same 41 42 43
years old and so you know this just kind
of gives Bill Belichick chance to
collect more data on where Tom Brady is
physically and then circle back and make
that decision in 2018 but what's
significant about it you know in my mind
at least is what he's giving up to get
there which would have been a
significant all coming back for Jimmy
Garoppolo is it possible in your mind
that Garoppolo and Brady are on the
roster next season I don't know how you
make it work logistically because you're
talking about okay so you tagging the 22
million right Tom Brady I believe is set
to make 15 million dollars in 2018 can
you have your starting quarterback
making people I mean what they we
integrate right class ed Brady's not
going to be back as the backup to grappa
right yeah so so I mean like you're
going to have Garoppolo at a minimum of
22 million dollars for 2018 right and
Brady's would be sitting there 15
million that he's always been event of
all to taking less but I can't imagine
that if you're Tom Brady you're going to
sit there and say I got my I'm going to
be okay with my backup making seven
million dollars more than me you know so
you know you know it's not just tagging
brothel it's also that you have to get
Brady a gigantic grades you know and
it's just and now you're talking about
getting to okay what are you going to be
spending on that position that's me
forty five fifty million dollars on that
position alone and that's almost a
thirty year salary cap so it's just I
and that's without even getting to how
uncomfortable it could be then you know
so it's just it's hard to envision a
scenario where you have both guys I'm
sure Garoppolo wants to play and he's
waited long enough
and so to me it's I don't know how you
get around 2018 being decision time for
the Patriots when it comes to Jimmy
Garoppolo versus Tom Brady before let's
go anything we should know on the Colin
Kaepernick front okay I'll tell you this
I will assume this chris i i i i think
one thing
a lot of people are missing here is the
Java starting quarterback Chris's backup
quarterback those are two different jobs
and I don't think he's a good fit in a
lot of places a backup quarterback for a
variety of reasons of course there's all
the extra tension need bring the scheme
fit there's a zillion reasons why as a
backup quarterback is not a good set a
lot of places but I think where the job
opportunity could come is if there's an
opportunity to be a starting quarterback
somewhere because that job is different
in you know it could be as simple as a
contender having a server go down
doesn't have a back-up situation and
says we need to find a way to create a
threat that's a little different to be
fair to the other guys in our roster
because we are a contender right now and
so to me I mean it feels like the ship
sailed on him being a backup somewhere
and right now the opportunity for him
would have to come with one of these
emergency situations where a starter
goes down and a team that's in a
position to contend is desperate but
remember I mean you know the free thing
that happen with Teddy but for Teddy
Bridgewater last August that those
things that happen every year so there's
the chance that that sort of situation
may not even arise a terrific stuff
Albert I always appreciate the time in
you head of Chris that's Albert brear
the MQB Sports Illustrated joining me
here on the Dan Patrick show the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience